[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a este programa
especial de migrantes a propósito del
Día Mundial del refugiado nos saluda
Juliette riaño
[Música]
cada 20 de junio se conmemora el Día
Mundial del refugiado una fecha para ser
visible la situación de millones de
personas que fueron obligadas a dejar
sus hogares por diferentes causas y
tuvieron que desplazarse en busca de
seguridad también es una fecha para
recordar los derechos de esta población
y alertar sobre las necesidades urgentes
de ayuda y protección por todo esto cada
junio la agencia de la ONU para los
refugiados presenta un informe que
detalla la situación de refugio y
desplazamiento en el mundo durante el
año anterior el más reciente revela lo
siguiente a finales de 2022
108,4 millones de personas huyeron como
resultado de persecución conflictos
violencia o violaciones a sus derechos
humanos un dato que se estima aumentó
hasta los 110 millones Durante los
primeros cinco meses de 2023 por la
continuidad acelerada de dichos
desplazamientos
el informe de acnur detalla además las
cifras de nacionalidades países de
acogida y desplazamiento interno veamos
más de la situación en el mundo en el
siguiente informe el desplazamiento en
el globo no para y las necesidades de
ayuda urgente y protección aumentan una
de cada 74 personas en el mundo fueron
obligadas a desplazarse durante el 2022
19 millones más en comparación con los
reportes de 2021 y las cosas no van
mejor en este 2023
aquí es donde nos encontramos hoy
tenemos 110 millones de personas que han
huido debido al conflicto la persecución
la discriminación la violencia a menudo
mezclada con otros motivos en particular
el impacto del cambio climático de
impacto climático el 52% de los que
cruzaron las fronteras provienen de solo
tres países Siria Ucrania y Afganistán y
los que huyeron lo hicieron en su
mayoría a países vecinos Turquía Irán y
Colombia son las Naciones que acogieron
al mayor número de refugiados en 2022
la mayoría de las personas que huyen no
huyen a países ricos sino a países de
ingresos bajos o medios
alrededor del 76% los desplazados
internos son más en número que los
refugiados y esta situación no parece
cambiar Durante este 2023 los conflictos
prolongados y los nuevos aumentan la
necesidad de huir por lo que la ONU
Llama a prestar atención a las crisis
actuales
de estas emergencias muy pocas aparecen
en los titulares y creo que Sudán es un
muy buen ejemplo
Esta es una emergencia muy importante
ahora por supuesto no es tan grande como
Ucrania Incluso en términos de personas
afectadas
pero tener casi dos millones de personas
en movimiento en menos de dos meses
desde el 15 de abril solo porque hay dos
líderes militares luchando por la
supremacía básicamente es una situación
bastante dramática
everywhere francamente Esto fue un
titular en todas partes hasta que hubo
ciudadanos occidentales que evacuaron
una vez hecho esto desapareció el
informe también llama la atención sobre
la situación de los niños y niñas que
representan el 40% de los desplazados y
refugiados en el mundo
en 2022 el conflicto entre Rusia y
Ucrania generó el desplazamiento más
veloz y uno de los de mayor magnitud
desde la Segunda Guerra Mundial para
profundizar en la situación de los
refugiados y desplazados en el mundo
hablamos con olgazarrado vocera de acnur
A ella le preguntamos sobre la acogida y
los miles que huyeron de Ucrania por la
guerra
tristemente ya ha pasado más de un año
desde que comenzó la guerra en Ucrania y
seguimos preocupados por la situación en
el país que continúa a
afectar a muchísimas familias a forzar
el desplazamiento de muchas personas
dentro del país y todavía algunas de
ellas continúan saliendo del país
una de las de los puntos positivos que
hemos podido sacar no de de esta
situación es que si se quiere se puede
la acogida de las personas refugiadas
ucranianas en los países vecinos a
Ucrania pero también
toda Europa y en el resto del mundo ha
sido un ejemplo de solidaridad de cómo
si se Si se quiere si se pone en
políticas si se dedican los fondos que
son necesarios para dar soluciones a las
personas refugiadas es posible darles
una solución darles la posibilidad de
vivir de una forma digna hasta que
puedan retornar a sus casas ya que
muchos de ellos pues vieron truncadas
sus vidas de un día para otro la acogida
de las personas ucranianas de las
personas refugiadas ucranianas ha sido
única con medidas legales que se
pusieron en marcha el año pasado y que
han favorecido su integración en las
comunidades de acogida les han permitido
acceder a las escuelas encontrar empleo
contribuir a los países en los que en
los que viven el informe que presenta a
Turquía y Colombia como los principales
receptores pero también aclara que los
países de renta baja y media reciben a
un 76% de los refugiados cómo explicar
esto Si vemos además que Aparentemente
son los países del Norte global los que
tendrían los mayores desafíos en sus
fronteras nos lo explica Olga sarrado
una de las cosas que uno de los puntos
que hemos observado y que se evidencian
en el en el reporte de tendencias de
desplazamiento forzado que acnur publicó
tan solo la semana pasada es que existen
muchos mitos y mitos que tenemos que
romper y estas cifras nos permiten
trabajar en ello no Muchas veces
pensamos que la mayoría de las personas
refugiadas o desplazadas quieren llegar
a Estados Unidos o quieren ir a la Unión
Europea y las cifras demuestran que no
es así el 76% de las personas refugiadas
se encuentran en países de renta baja o
media y el 70% 7 de cada 10 se quedan en
países vecinos a su país de origen
porque es esto porque lo que nos dicen
la gran mayoría de las personas
refugiadas es que lo que quieren es
quedarse cerca de su país para poder
volver en cuanto haya paz sobre América
Latina los venezolanos optaron por
volver a desplazarse desde el lugar que
los acogió o por el retorno
Esta es la situación en las Américas
según actor
en cuanto a las personas venezolanas
observamos que hay personas refugiados
inmigrantes que están tomando la
decisión de devolver porque sienten que
pueden hacerlo en seguridad que tienen
esa confianza no de retornar a sus
hogares Y poder continuar con la vida
que tenían antes También estamos viendo
a personas venezolanas pero también de
muchas otras nacionalidades que se
lanzan
en rutas muy peligrosas como por ejemplo
a través del Darién o hemos visto
también en los últimos días no la
situación en la frontera de México y
Estados Unidos y la mayoría de estas
personas nos cuentan no que no han
encontrado allí donde se estaban esa
estabilidad que necesitaban sobre todo
con el impacto socioeconómico después de
covid y no han visto otra posibilidad
más que continuar una ruta y buscar esa
estabilidad en otro lugar pero lo más
importante y que no tenemos que olvidar
Es que la gran mayoría de las personas
venezolanas refugiadas inmigrantes a día
de hoy continúan en países de América
Latina y también en países del Caribe en
el informe Se nombra además a la crisis
climática como otra de las consecuencias
de los nuevos desplazamientos los
fenómenos causados por el calentamiento
global podrían convertirse en los
causantes de un Éxodo masivo en algunas
regiones así lo explica la agencia de la
ONU para los refugiados
estos efectos del cambio climático se
entremezclan con situaciones de pobreza
con situaciones de conflicto anteriores
lo que incrementa ese impacto y puede
llevar a la gente a desplazarse dentro
del país dentro de su propio país pero
también a otros países Entonces es
importante trabajar en prevenir en
mitigar el impacto de esa crisis
climática que es una evidencia y es una
realidad en todo el mundo para evitar
esos desplazamientos y equipar a las a
las comunidades
con los elementos necesarios para poder
hacer frente a ello lo observamos por
ejemplo un ejemplo de ellos En el cuerno
de África pero específicamente en
somalia donde en el último año más de
millón y medio de personas se han visto
desplazadas por una mezcla de
del impacto de la crisis climática pero
que también ha llevado a la hambruna y
mezclada con situaciones de conflicto
Entonces es muy importante que que
trabajemos entre todos y que invirtamos
no en esa en trabajar para esa
prevención y esa mitigar esas ese
impacto del cambio climático
y las previsiones para 2023 no son
buenas la continuidad de la guerra en
Ucrania y la intensificación de otros
conflictos como el de Sudán podrían
llevar una crisis humanitaria de mayores
proporciones Olga cerrado o será de
acnur nos habló sobre lo que prevé acnur
para el término del año en curso
desde que comenzó el año hemos visto un
terremoto que impactó la frontera de
Turquía y Siria que ha llevado a muchas
personas a que lleva muchas personas a
desplazarse de nuevo para para encontrar
seguridad hemos visto ya más de dos
millones de personas desplazadas por la
guerra de Sudán en menos de dos meses
hemos visto hay que continúa la
violencia por ejemplo en la República
democrática del Congo
estamos tan solo a mitad de año y ya
hemos respondido a casi el mismo número
de emergencias a las que respondimos
como como acnur el año anterior Así que
este año no no esperamos que sea mucho
mejor que la anterior y además estamos
viendo que muchos de estos conflictos
están también incrementando el costo de
la ayuda humanitaria y también cada vez
los fondos y la financiación que estamos
recibiendo las organizaciones
humanitarias es menor
y esto está dificultando que llegue esa
ayuda a las personas que más lo
necesitan Entonces lo principal y lo que
necesitamos todos es que haya paz si no
hubiera conflictos no se necesitarías
ayuda humanitaria y las personas no
estarían obligadas a dejar sus hogares
para para salvar sus vidas Entonces lo
más importante es que la comunidad
internacional trabaje por acabar con
esos conflictos por por lograr la paz y
y por permitir que las personas que se
han tenido que desplazar puedan retornar
a sus hogares y evitar que haya nuevos
desplazamientos este año Pero por
desgracia a día de hoy a mitad de año
las tendencias no son muy positivas en
un contexto de mayores desplazamientos
el llamado es a decir no alas xenofobia
y si a la integración hasta que
inmigrantes de France 24 los invitamos a
comentar en nuestras redes sociales con
el hashtag migrante f24 sigan con más
información en 24.com
[Música]